greetings everyone this is rob sanders
with
simply learn and welcome to today's
edition
today we're going to talk about digital
marketing through facebook
so there's lots to cover so sit back
enjoy take some notes and feel free to
comment in the comment section
so let's start out with facebook itself
okay so facebook obviously social
networking platform
it's been around for a few years but
it's come a long way i mean today
on facebook you can host 360 degree
videos
uh you could sell products via chat bot
you could
basically be a news network on facebook
i mean we've all seen the results of
that
over the past few years internationally
that's where people go to get their news
so it's really come a long way
in fact you know facebook
basically has about 1.5 billion
daily active users that's a lot of
people engaging in the network
according to hubspot the average user
spends about
60 minutes per day on facebook that's an
hour of 24
spent just on the social media platform
now a lot of people gravitate towards
facebook
a lot of different ages demographics
countries use facebook for again for
various reasons
but despite all its use despite all this
hubspot is reporting that only 48
percent of marketers
think that their facebook efforts are
effective
only 48 is less than half of marketers
in other words are frustrated with
facebook you know
there's a lot you can do with facebook
and so that's what we're going to focus
today's session on
all the things that you should be doing
on facebook to better engage
with your users okay so first thing
we're going to talk about
is really setting up the perfect
facebook page
okay so that's i think where a lot of
companies go wrong i think
people are just quick to jump on to
facebook as a network
just because their competitors are on
there
somebody told them they had to be on
facebook and then what happens
they get a you know 50 effort
output on the facebook page with no
updated post
no information no best practices applied
so basically the old saying is garbage
in garbage out
that's what you get when you don't
follow best practices or apply
all the best features facebook's has to
offer
so really when it comes to setting up a
facebook page
you want to start with the basics you
want to have a good profile picture
first of all i mean if it's you yes you
want a picture of you
but if you're representing a company
organization
you really got to give second thought
about what that profile picture is going
to be
you know obviously relevancy comes to
mind but
you know is it in good taste is it
updated is it fit
the brand guidelines of the organization
okay
then you wanna you know you can also
accompany that profile picture with a
cover photo
so again you ask yourself you know
is the cover photo outdated is it recent
is it in good taste and i think this is
where a lot of people go wrong
and that's really adding a good
description
not a dissertation by any means but
you know a short description that just
explains what the organization or
company is all about
you know just you know common sense but
you
would think that uh adding a description
wouldn't be a big deal but
you know it is a big deal because you
want people to know what you're all
about
and you want to create a good username
for your page
because that's a that's a username
people are going to
hopefully remember so you want to pick
wisely there
you don't want something long something
that people aren't going to remember or
misspell when they try and type it in
you could certainly add your page to
shortcuts
and when you actually set up your page
you have several roles that you can
assign to people
so my advice is if you're going to
operate a facebook page
for your organization or company add
multiple people to the page to help out
you're not going to be able to do
everything on facebook by yourself
unless that's your sole
job 24 hours a day because there's lots
and lots and lots of things you could be
doing on facebook
so set up a role you can play the role
of admin
but you have other roles that you can
assign to other people within the
organization you can assign editors
moderators people to handle just the
advertising
or you can hire just or assign an
analyst role to people
who can go in and just look at the
results of your post
so you have various page roles that you
can assign
on facebook now the other important
feature when you're working with a
facebook page is to customize the
notifications
okay you want to be notified when
somebody responds
likes engages you want to set up
notifications for your ads if you're
running facebook ads
so there's lots of notifications so make
sure you customize
those so that you're in the know
on a daily basis okay and
one other best practice that i don't
necessarily see all that
often on a facebook page and that's
adding a cta
or call to action so don't be afraid
to move people from the ecosystem of
facebook
to your website where likely there's
more information
so add a good call to action on the
facebook page
you can keep people within the
environment and ecosystem of facebook or
you can move them to your website or
blog
or you know somewhere else just add a
cta
let people do something when they're on
your page that's really the point of the
cta
so those are just some of the best
practices for
really setting up a facebook page i mean
again there's lots
of things you can do we're going to talk
about more of those as we move forward
but just doing those basic things just
making sure
you know you keep those photos and those
pictures up to date
uh you know change the description every
once in a while
play around with the cta you know just
continue to
you know keep the page vibrant it's like
watering a plan if
you don't keep it updated it's going to
die
and people are going to recognize that
so
you have your facebook page you do have
an option
and if you want to reach more people on
facebook you have the option of
advertising
on facebook and so you have something
called just basically classic ads on
facebook so
the whole idea of advertising on
facebook is again
if your goal is to generate more
you know likes on your page or maybe
it's to drive people directly to your
website
that's basically what you can do that's
that's you have to pick
what your strategy is okay or your
objective
so facebook's going to guide you through
that process if you're interested in
advertising
now the great thing i like about
facebook advertising unlike say
paid search edge on google is that you
can really hone in on your audience
you know it could be a specific
demographic or some
a group of people who have the same
interest that you're trying to promote
so the benefits of running advertising
on facebook is you can really hone in on
who your audience is
you can also decide where to run your ad
i mean facebook has
an advertising network if you will
that includes facebook messenger
instagram obviously news feed
email so there's a lot of things that
you can choose from
with facebook so you want to be able to
pick and choose where you want to run
those ads
and facebook advertising has multiple
types of ad formats anything from
videos to to images so you could pick
your format
test your format you know the thing i
also like about facebook advertising
because anybody who's seen my videos in
the past
knows that i'm a big proponent of a b
testing so
within facebook ads manager there are
components to
set up a b testing on call to actions
and so
to me that's a great feature of
advertising you always want to test what
people react to
and so that's built into ads manager
and of course when you're advertising on
facebook you can control it all with a
budget
so facebook's going to let you know you
know basically based on who your
audience is
where you're advertising what your
objective is
this is how many people you're going to
reach this is what they recommend on the
budget so
you can go with a recommended budget or
you can just choose your own budget
the whole idea though behind advertising
on facebook
is to really hone in on a strategy
okay why are we going to spend money on
facebook
you know is it to generate leads again
is it just to generate
more engagement on our facebook page so
you really want to give it some thought
before you dive in and start spending
money
when you do make that dive and you do
start advertising
again there's a lot of things that you
can take advantage of with facebook
advertising
um there's there's lead ads
you know basically allowing people to
submit a form right then and there
there's video ads as i mentioned video
ads to me
are probably going to be the most
effective and impactful
of all the forms of advertising because
that's what people want they want video
nowadays they want to be able to
read and listen and engage
you can run engagement ads you can
remarket on facebook meaning
target people who've already been to
your facebook page or been to your
website
you can do interest targeting meaning if
you have a group of people
who have the same interest as your
organization
maybe that could be you know picking up
plastic from the ocean
okay there are probably a large
amount of people on facebook who share
that same interest
i know i do i have that interest so
there's always an interest
out there to be had and targeted
of course you have with facebook you
have demographic targeting based on age
and gender
and you have behavioral targeting now
behavioral targeting to me
is the hidden gem of facebook so
for instance you could target ads to
people who say purchased
a piece of clothing for you okay so if
they purchase you can retarget them
based on a previous behavior purchasing
a piece of clothing
i mean if you're selling health products
or beauty products or
pet products it doesn't matter you know
the behavior is all going to be the same
you can pick and choose
based on that behavior so
behavioral targeting to me is a
a good feature to take advantage of if
you're going to run facebook ads
another thing i like about facebook
advertising
is uh basically the use of carousel ads
so carousel ads are basically
multiple images or or videos
so instead of just running one video out
or one image ad you can
put them together and you can have i
believe up to 10
so within the same ad unit so you can
have a rotating
imagery if you will or carousel of
images
and so basically the what great thing
about this is it's interactive it allows
you to put
more of your message and more of your
brand more of your focus out front
and i found through my experience at
carousel ads 10 along with video ads
tend to work
really well okay so
just keep that in mind if you're gonna
do facebook advertising
you know keep some of these features in
mind in terms of behavioral targeting
demographic
targeting you know running lead ads or
carousel ads
the other thing that you should know
about facebook advertising
is the use of a facebook pixel
so what does that facebook pixel mean
well it means that if you want to
drive traffic from your advertising to
your website
you want to be able to track that
behavior and that's what the facebook
pixel does it allows you
to basically track website behavior
when somebody comes from your facebook
ad so
if you insert the facebook pixel
directly on your website then facebook
will be able to tell you
in its own reporting console what people
have done did they
engage once they went to your website
did they convert meaning
download something fill out a form
submission purchase something
okay so keep that facebook pixel in mind
so if you're going to run advertising on
facebook that's what you want to do you
want to be able to leverage that
facebook pixel
now let's switch over to some of the
other things that you can do
on facebook and so if you have a large
number of followers
if you're a popular brand or even if
you're trying to generate
more likes and more followers on your
facebook page
then you know a contest is probably not
a bad idea i mean who doesn't like a
contest
so to me you can run a facebook contest
right on facebook you know very simple
idea
but you know if you apply some of the
best practices
it could really pay off for you so let
me just run through
some of the best practices in setting up
a facebook contest
first things first you have to choose a
price
so in my opinion
i think a gift card tends to work best
as a price
um it could be for a specific store
united states you know target
and walmart are always good or apple if
you want to really go higher end
or just something very generic maybe a
25
50 gift card to amazon where you can
allow
the winner to choose what they want
regardless of the specifics gift cards
are always
flexible to use okay so it ensures that
entrance
of the contest have an interest in your
products
okay which you know if they have an
interest then they're going to be easier
to convert into a sale
so you want to offer something that's
going to be of interest
okay the next thing you need to do is
decide what the users
have to do to enter so in my opinion you
want to make it as simple as possible
but get what you need to get
so do they need to submit a photo
you know i've run facebook contests in
the past for some of my clients
you know photos always tend to work
because that's what people tend to do on
facebook anyway
is submit photos okay so a little bit
more
behind the photo is you want to capture
something along with that photo
so to me an email address you know tends
to work
that way you have something of value
along with that photo
that way you can leverage that email
later on down the road whether you do
email marketing
or facebook lookalike or something of
that nature
okay so you have to decide
what it is you're going to ask users to
do so keep it easy but get something of
value in return
so once you've made those preliminary
decisions build your facebook
ex build your facebook contest page so
make the contest page simple but
exciting
okay so that's the whole point you want
people to
enter so you want to have attention
grabbing titles
you want to use high quality images you
want to obviously enter
in the prize information and the contest
information
the the important dates when it starts
when it ends
okay you want to have that all important
submission form again that goes
back to what are you capturing are you
capturing just name and email address
are you capturing name email address
city
other information like interest are you
adding questions so just be careful on
the submission form
and then you want to be able to you know
have share buttons
and allow facebook comments as well okay
so
when you build your contest page then
you obviously want to promote your
contest
i'd like to think that goes without
saying that
you can use other social platforms like
twitter
linkedin instagram tick tock to
promote the contest on facebook you want
to get people there and participate
another option could be running the
facebook ads for the contest that's
probably not a bad idea
so remember you can use carousel ads or
or
lead ads or your behavioral targeting
or interest targeting you can use all
those ad features i mentioned a couple
minutes ago
to help drive traffic to that contest
page
and get contestants so obviously you run
the contest you monitor the contest
facebook has something called facebook
insights built
in right into facebook's platform so
you'll be able to
measure the results of the contest and
then when the contest is all said and
done
well what do you want to do well you
want to profile the winner okay so
you want to let everybody know hey
contest is over
so and so on and you want to share those
results on facebook and other social
networks
i mean you can even create a video
showing the winner
to generate a little bit more excitement
you can send
follow-up in fact i would even recommend
you send follow-up emails to all the
people who entered into the contest
okay thank them hey that gets you
closer to getting more sales okay
and then you could tease people with a
future contest
so at the end of the day contests are
always a good idea
to generate more excitement more brand
more buzz
now moving on from the contest another
thing that you can do on facebook is
promote your post
so if you're not doing any paid
advertising
however you're posting a lot on facebook
you have the option to
promote your post and so what does that
mean
so basically it's a form of advertising
using some of your organic post and it
just allows you
to allow that post to get more
visibility okay it allows you to market
it
in the news feed so more people can see
it okay
so you choose your post you set a budget
and then the post is shared to a set
number of facebook members
okay and so you could turn it on and off
that promoted post
anytime you want okay now from my
experience
promoter posts are really good uh it's a
really inexpensive way to
highlight a specific post that you feel
needs attention
so if you're posting a lot and you feel
that post is to get buried
and doesn't get the visibility that it
deserves then consider promoting it
it's really in my opinion cost effective
now i know that's all relevant but
promoting a post definitely generates a
lot more awareness so if you have really
something important to say
and show then consider promoting it it's
it's really
that simple it's just right there within
the post facebook allows you the option
to go ahead and just promote it
with said budget the other thing you can
do
on facebook it's sponsored stories
so really sponsor stories are just
short user photo and video collections
that can be viewed
a few times and they disappear
after 24 hours it's it's really similar
to
users who operate on snapchat that's
basically the concept behind it it's
just focused around
facebook's in-app camera okay which
you can overlay with filters and lenses
just like you can on snapchat
and you can add some visual effects and
tags and
and also you can have fun with it
basically so a sponsor story
is just you know it allows you to
manipulate
videos and photos to tell a more
complete story in a more fun way
basically so have fun with sponsored
stories on facebook
another thing that you could take
advantage of and this is something i
would recommend
is using facebook's open graph so
what is facebook open graph uh
so for those that aren't familiar it's
been around a while i think
we're in 2021 to 2010 that's how long
facebook open graph has been around it's
just simply a protocol
and what that protocol does it extracts
certain elements from your page so
title images url and other meta
information
from your website and
what facebook does is pull that
information
and that's what they're going to display
in social post so it allows basically
your website to communicate with
facebook
and allow you to control what
information gets
said and seen in facebook okay
or which elements of your page you
really want somebody to
share regarding your website so that's
basically what a facebook open graph is
okay so that's something you implement
on your own website
so moving on from facebook open graph
you have facebook exchange uh also known
as
fbx okay so that's been around a few
years as well
i think 2012 is uh
when it launched and it's just a
platform for advertising services to
desktop users
okay so that's the key it's it's really
for desktop users it's not available on
the
facebook mobile app okay and it just
allows you to do
real-time bid purchases it allows online
advertisers
really to place ads onto facebook
sidebar
or directly onto a user's timeline as
they scroll down
okay so it just allows you an advertiser
to get your product out there a little
bit more
okay so you have
sponsor stories you have open graph you
have facebook exchange you have
facebook advertising promoted post you
have all sorts of options available on
facebook
i think the key thing though to remember
when you're on facebook
is to always provide value so what do i
mean by providing value
so think of it as value-added content
and so value-added content because
that's basically what you're doing
you're promoting
or pushing content on their platform
you want it to be unique and original
you want to be exclusive content or
information that your audience really
can't get
anywhere else okay so that's the whole
idea behind value-added content
you know you can repost and rehash what
other people have written
but to me the whole idea behind facebook
is to write something really unique
that really resonates with your audience
okay and if you can do that you're
probably going to
naturally gain more followers and
generate more likes and engagement
on your facebook page okay the other
thing you want to do
along with that value-added content is
really in my opinion i've talked about
this on
other webinar sessions with simply learn
and that's really
generating or leveraging a social media
platform
like a sprout social
or hootsuite and why do you want to
leverage those is because
it allows you to really just create a
content counter
think about the content the value-added
content you're going to
publish ahead of time and it allows you
to consistently
publish at a good time and day
and so you're consistent with your
publishing and your schedule
that's the whole point beyond using a
social media platform
if you don't not a big deal you can go
right into facebook
it's just like clockwork and and publish
when you feel it's the right time to
publish i mean everybody's publishing
schedule is going to be different
everybody lives in different time zones
everybody everybo
every company's audience is different um
and let's let's just face it the that
the
you know there's gonna be
differentiation so there's not a set
schedule it's just what you're
comfortable with that's gonna be right
for you and your audience
the key is consistency so and that's
where the social media platforms like
the hood sweets and the
sprout socials come into play now
a couple other things you want to do to
take advantage
of facebook engage with your fans
meaning if somebody comments
positively or negatively go ahead and
engage with them in a positive manner
okay you know put some focus on
relevancy when it comes to your fans
okay so you always want to attract
people who have
like-minded interest always keep that in
mind
now if you're trying to build more fans
and followers you could
certainly use graph search and basically
all graph searches
is typing something in to the
feed bar on facebook a keyword basically
and if you type in say coffee shops or
something of that nature you know
basically facebook's going to allow you
to see
you know pages that your friends have
liked
friends who you know live near or excuse
me coffee shops who live nearby
so it's going to give you some feedback
and other suggestions
based on that keyword or interest
so take advantage of the graph search on
facebook
to generate like-minded
or similar pages it allows you to find
people that you can connect with on
facebook
now the last thing we're going to talk
about
with facebook is metrics
always my favorite subject for those
that have listened to me for a while
know that i am big not only on just a b
testing
but on measuring data and so of course
just like you know google analytics or
any other
social networking platform facebook has
its own set
of metrics and so i'm just going to run
through
some of those metrics that you should be
aware of
and so we're going to start out with
engagement
so engagement is in my opinion probably
the number one metric you want to
measure
within facebook's ecosystem not
necessarily the most important
however it is at the top of the list
okay obviously conversions are always
going to trump everything but engagement
is a form of conversion
people are engaging with your post or
with your contest or with a video
and so that's really all engagement is
it's just a number of times somebody
took
action on your post okay whether they
they
liked it whether they shared it whether
they left a comment
those are all forms of engagement so
to me engagement allows you to really
see
over a period of time over a period of
post how well you're performing
and you want to leverage engagement to
make adjustments to your post i mean if
you've posted
say 20 posts on facebook and you've got
no engagement
then you probably want to circle back
and think about
what kind of post you're writing are you
adding value-added content
to your relevant audience that's really
the key with engagement
okay reach is another metric reach is
just the number of times
people have seen your content on
facebook that's all that's all it is
okay then excuse me reach is the number
of people your content is seen by
on facebook so so that's all reach
is okay so reach is a number that
takes into account both organic and paid
okay so how many people
is your post really reaching whether
that be paid or organic
okay and so obviously that number you
want
as big as possible so you're going to
probably start out small but you want
that to grow
because that's where the engagement part
goes in the more
your post engage the more people are
going to like the more people going to
connect with you and the bigger your
reach is going to be
so the other metric is impressions
and so impressions is basically the
visibility
okay of your post okay how many people
saw your post
that's impression okay so
you know if you're reaching 100 people
of those hundred people how many people
saw it how many impressions did you have
now
it's a hundred you obviously want a
hundred if it's ten thousand
you want ten thousand impressions and so
you want as many
people possible to see that post and if
they haven't and it's an important post
then remember you have the option to
promote that post and so that's going to
give you the
boost you need to go ahead and and get
more visibility for that specific post
so you can
increase the impression counts okay
now the other thing you want to measure
with facebook is referral traffic so
if you're running a contest and sending
people back to your site
where you're running facebook ads and
sending people back to your website
you want to leverage google analytics or
similar tool
to measure how much referral traffic
facebook actually drove
okay so that to me is key
if you're driving traffic back to your
website so always keep that in mind
okay how much traffic is facebook really
driving
and more importantly of the traffic
that's going to my website how much of
that is converting
so that's something you want to look at
of course if you're running a facebook
page and you're not doing any facebook
advertising
page likes or something you want to keep
a tab on
okay how many people liked or followed
you directly on your page
okay obviously you want that number to
grow over time
okay again it goes hand in hand with the
the amount of content the value-added
content
that you're posting on facebook okay so
obviously with facebook ads or organic
post on facebook you have the option of
videos
and so if you're going to post videos
then you want to be able to see
retention meaning what percentage of
your videos were watched
okay and so to me that's important
because if i post a good video and it's
say
30 seconds and i didn't get that many
people to watch it
then what does that say about the
quality of the video or vice versa if i
have a two minute video
and i have a large percentage of the
people who only saw
say 25 to 30 seconds what does that tell
you you need to kind of compress that
video down
so retention to me is an important
metric on facebook related to videos and
then obviously engagement
remember i said earlier that most people
like
to engage with videos on facebook
and so you want to be able to measure
the amount of likes
shares or comments that that video
received so
retention engagement are both available
for
videos on facebook and then rounding out
the metrics when you're doing
facebook ads you're going to have some
key metrics that you're going to want to
measure
okay aside from cost you want to really
measure click-through rate
and click-through rate basically is just
the percentage of people
that saw your ad and then clicked on
your ad that's all click-through rate is
okay so you want a very high
click-through rate obviously if 100
people sell your ad
you obviously want 100 people to click
on the ad
the thing about facebook advertising is
the cost
model could be cost per impression or
cost per click so if it's cost per click
obviously you want that number to be as
low as possible that's the whole idea
so if you get 100 people clicking on
your ad
then obviously if that cost per click is
low then you're not spending as much so
to me it's better to pay say 500 for
1500 clicks
then say paying 500 for 250 clicks
obviously the 1500 is all means your cpc
is a lot lower than the
two dollars you were spending for 250
clicks at a cost of 500
so that's the whole key here is to
try and run ads and keep that cost per
click low
okay so the other metric you want to
measure with facebook ads
is cost per acquisition or cpa
okay and basically that just measures
the cost
based on a specific action so if you're
asking somebody to fill out a form
submission
okay how much did it actually cost you
in advertising dollars to get
a person to do just that fill out a form
submission
okay if it was a hundred dollars then
you got to ask yourself wow is that high
obviously cost per acquisition numbers
always need to be low
okay so if you're selling t-shirts at
the
at a cost of say ten dollars if your
cost per acquisition is ten dollars
okay you're in trouble you wanna keep
that cost for acquisition
number as low as possible so that's a
key metric to always keep in mind
for facebook advertising
and then another metric to kind of look
at or keep an eye on is ad frequency
so how many times did people see my ad
okay so you want to be able to show your
ad
probably at most two to three times i
mean if somebody's seen your
advertisement
five six seven times they're just going
to ignore it and so to me those are just
wasted impressions and so you want to
be able to control your ad frequency the
number of times
you want somebody to see your ad it
could be one time it could be two times
but you obviously don't want somebody to
see your ad five six seven
times otherwise you're just not going to
get probably much out of that
so those are all the different types of
metrics available
in facebook you know heed my advice
pay close attention to the metrics
that's going to tell you
a lot about how your facebook page is
performing
so that does it for us today on digital
marketing through facebook
i appreciate your attention if anybody
has any comments or questions
feel free right below this video to add
them
and we're more than happy to respond
accordingly
so i want to thank you again i look
forward to our next video
in the meantime take care
you